foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the break room this is
our daily live show that keeps you
updated on all the nerdy fandom news you
need to know coming up on the show today
War Games returned to Survivor Series
this year oh my gosh I wish we were
talking about that thanks and coming
choo choo is that the king train yeah I
wrote these
awesome also on today's show James
Cameron gets madder than usual he's at
he's usually out of seven
also House of the Dragons more like
House of the old people
that's like a road
yeah you sold it don't add afterwards
the Jessica wrote it well I did I
apologize commit commitment dragons more
like House of the old people yeah you
have to explain the joke it's called
House of the old people because of the
time Jump oh we'll get into it we'll get
it and also our favorite Heroes go to
real life events won't it be great hey
I'm Brandon but who cares with me on the
show today we got Tom Michaelson uh also
who cares whatever hey thanks for having
me here guys I guess thank you
and next to him and in between him and I
Jessica Clements uh who cares like it
balances Cup on my head though that's
very oh oh I swore I thought your hand
was holding on the other side wow it was
full of fire ants that's the peak of the
show build out everywhere sorry
[Laughter]
I love this show during too much
happening and it's a problem that's true
hey hey y'all hey y'all it's Monday and
it's show number 99.
demise our big 100th show we had to cut
down to only three people on the break
room today to make room for tomorrow's
show it's so heavy too much shell so
much energy back into it nuclear fission
baby uh but it is a Monday so for our
chat Redemption today we're going to be
doing Monday motivations so for every
hundred dollars we make it super chats
we'll give you all a little bit of
motivation and the voice of one of these
wonderful characters on the wheel uh do
you want to give them a small
demonstration you got to spin the wheel
real fast
and please don't be anyone with that
accent who'd you get
funny that's our kind of humor what is
that what
oh he goes hey everybody
you guys help me get in though
you're gonna have to bench press a lot
oh it's so good and go look here film
juice trash bags you know what you are
you're trash you're nothing else don't
look at my biceps don't look at my legs
don't comment on me I'm really strong
and the hottest person on the break room
uh yeah wow I thought Zach was here of
what you'll get uh give me anyone else
on that board and I could probably do it
we got like Beyonce in the board we got
this devil oh the devil Hulk Hogan
possibly problematic I don't know does
that say our Brandon yeah it's you who's
the
great Point
who wrote these names I drank this and
then you told me to write there I wrote
Jessica Alba she's a fun Macy Gray's on
there I want to see some Jessica now
yeah what's that gonna look like if
someone could pull off a Jessica Alba
call it boy is on there all of us are
awesome so yeah send in those super
chats uh we appreciate them Anika Mishra
also said already standing in Super Chat
we love you Tom oh hey yeah send them in
and if you got certain things you want
motivation for if you got topics you
want us to address our motivational
speeches put those in the super chats uh
uh we love to do it uh and we love to
motivate you on this wonderful Monday uh
but that's enough of that Jess I think
we should get into it don't you it's
time for hello
[Music]
we got it we got it
big trailer too is uh Kang's new powers
that d23 I don't think we have the
snippet because it hasn't been released
has it come out yet we've got a little
media attraction uh it's one of the
things we haven't really addressed uh
which we were talking about all the d23
news in the trailer you kind of see Kang
throw with his mind uh we assume uh
Scott line like up against the wall so
like different Kings kind of have
different powers in the comics right and
like the original King he had a little
telekinesis you know what I mean he
could just move things with his mind so
it looks like this King will have at
least that power as well they also had a
another king have a chair that could do
this stuff too so it's like he could
press a button in his chair will do it
or something weird like kind of old
school uh invisible chair where they
just do the dash lines to indicate that
it's like kind of invisible after that
it kind of just looked I always thought
it looks so weird it looks like a Glam
shell or something I hope they do that
yeah I know what you're talking about I
mean sometimes he has like a weird
little gun they always liked weird
little yeah pistols like doctor Dooms
like one pistol
I hope they do that so that all the big
bads that bring the Avengers together
are all just villains of sit in chairs
like six years yeah before he came out
in Infinity War so you want to do the
movement
that's hard enough yeah
I did not but I was here covering it
with a horizon I was there I was holding
it down I wasn't Costa Rica oh that's
right you saw the actual trailer I saw
it I saw the trailer with my own eyes
wow exclusive exclusive it's all on
inside this brand if only you had an
Inception machine oh it'll come out or a
magic chair that could just siphon it
out of your head
yeah exactly tell me chair tell me I
hate it uh you guys if you aren't up to
date but I will give it to you today the
house of the Dragon just time jumped by
just it's for the sixth episode the
fifth episode they're still the young
people the sixth episode will no longer
have the young kiddos yeah the previews
we knew they were going to grow up soon
but it's coming it's time to fast
forward it is sad I don't like it uh and
we're running a poll in the chat right
now if you've been watching the uh House
of the Dragon which of the four young
actors that are going to age up that
you're you're sad to see AJ so the four
are um let's see Rainier Allison Kristen
and well no it's gonna be Rainier
Allison and then the the layers oh the
valerian
maybe he's already a 30 year old man and
they're just pretending he's a high
schooler like Toby McGuire and
Spider-Man for sure yeah maybe they just
take the wig off because yeah yeah you
notice strong they just put like gray
hair going further down his face and his
hair shorter and I was like oh okay but
then viserys looks like the Crypt Keeper
yeah we've been talking uh talking
dragons on talking dragons Jessica and I
covered in the after shows you've been
checking that out on the channel uh uh
Eric's breakdown of this most recent
episode will be up on the channel
tomorrow
um but yeah it is a little sad to see
them jump up and this show originally
wasn't even gonna have the young actors
really I think the original con concept
of the show was going to start where
we're about to begin and lose a lot of
this backstory because like in the book
for instance uh it's not clear weather
there's no talking about like Allison
and Rainier and knowing each other when
they were younger and actually in the
book Allison's like 10 years old yeah
but I think this added stuff they've
done in the show is like very helpful
and puts a lot of context into the
craziness that's about to happen I love
House of dragons oh my God it's so good
so good I liked it actually from the
jump to be fair I guess because I was
like this is very exciting I remember
when I when the first app came out and I
was watching everything I was like right
here is no Daenerys let's go and now on
this episode I'm like read here no don't
leave young green area you're my
favorite about it we talk about it and I
genuinely do not care about Rainier oh
mezzo uh I need you to go go eat
something today
um the headline
James Cameron always gets what he wants
whoa and Cameron always gets what he
wants in an interview with the New York
Times James Cameron disclosed how he
clashed with 20th centuries box
regarding trimming the movie's flying
scene Avatar's flying scene for time he
said I just drew a line in the sand and
said you know what I made Titanic this
building that we're meeting in right now
this new half billion dollar complex on
your lot Titanic paid for that so I get
to do this
damn James
wow
conceited much
but that's true that's true that's true
you this guy like does Titanic right
huge movie sets worldwide records kind
of takes some time off for a while he's
gone for a little while does it make
another major movie and then Mike comes
with Avatar and Mike does it again right
and invented the 3D Boom of yeah
genre of movies for five years
uh and now he's gonna do it again he has
the guts to be like no one's making 3D
movies anymore he's like I'm doing it
again so get get the glasses ready yeah
get your glasses in storage yes I'm
coming back the idea that and okay so
the thing is when I say he's allowed to
be conceited no one's allowed to be just
a bright butthole totally totally that
you're working with but he literally you
see sends him some true things there I
mean he paid for that building I think
it's changed now but yeah for a long
time he made the two highest grossing
things in America
the world I mean it's the first it's the
first uh Avatar long yeah it's long
could you cut a couple scenes probably
yeah but I'm not gonna fight James
Cameron about it and flying scene maybe
should have been ones to keep actually
yeah there could have been a ton of
other ones yeah the flying scene
actually was it seems like you can cut
that part out right yeah I mean when I
saw in Detroit they showed like a couple
it was all deleted scenes right
to show them like out of context and
there is like a similar sequence where
they're like oh you have to learn how to
ride these swimming the water Beast yeah
it seems a little similar to the whole
like you gotta learn how to flat you
ride the flying ones so I don't know
James the way of water not taking this
out that's the way James are here
I'll still see the movie I'm so excited
I'm not gonna give you notes my guy you
know I got a few notes we'll talk later
we'll talk later don't fight me I love
you James found the Titanic ocean and
he'll put you down there
yeah I know no one asked him he's like
camera you don't need to ask I'm gonna
do it he made the Titanic just so he
could go find it yes yes and make his
other little documentary I'm surprised
he's not making a spaceship to go to
space and look for Pandora
if you've never seen uh the the abyss
great movie Very insane look up the
watch it and look up the alternate
engine he wanted to originally have for
that movie but uh if if if you don't
even want to do that watch the
documentary about the making of that
movie The Man almost killed Ed Harris oh
like damn insane stuff they did for that
movie they had to invent all the
technology they filmed so much of that
movie underwater and these like
unfinished nuclear reactor tubs like
insanity go watch the making of that
movie crazy stuff the guy he I got a bag
I don't know what happened but I can
already imagine him holding the
microwave okay ed hold your breath hold
hold hold hold hold
keep holding that's literally what oh no
Ed Harris was dragged underwater without
mask and it was like crazy stuff I mean
he had cameraman underwater for like
hours and hours and hours at a time they
had to invent like different uh radio
underwater radio helmets to talk to each
other he keeps inventing new technology
for his movies yeah it was crazy okay
enough about this crazy James crazy man
in our poll where we asked which young
actor Will we missed the most 72 percent
said Rainier Targaryen I mean I mean
just it's free 72 of the feet no I love
Milly alcohol
I'm saying out of everyone on this show
Rainer is the only person that will
never be at fault because she's a
princess and everyone else's head will
be on his bike because of her actions
I'm sad to lose uh the um the woman
playing Alice said who hasn't had much
to do but had a great episode she had a
great what to do last uh great episode
last night I was like oh man she's just
about Emily Carey is amazing and her
tick tocks are so fun because she's like
not the highest build actress and she's
so happy to just have her own Funko Pop
so her tick tocks are her just dancing
around her Allison Funko Pop she's so
sweet I mean hopefully for the next
season they'll have like flashbacks they
can bring back yeah right yeah I I love
the young actors I wish they could stay
forever uh does this quote make you love
James Cameron more or less 61 said more
just like me
do you think all the king variants have
the same Powers 77th president said no
yeah I agree with that they should also
have different powers yeah that makes
sense yeah all right one one more
headline for y'all wakanda forever may
be canceled in France and when we say it
might be canceled this is all due to
French law requiring theatrical release
films to wait 17 months before releasing
on a subscription-based streaming
platform currently none of the MCU
movies from phase four have made it into
the streaming in France because of said
interesting 17 months so you so okay
think if you will movies like no way
home that went back in theaters does
that add on to the 17 months oh that's
interesting I don't I don't know
that one is a longer cut so maybe not
like that one in particular because
technically they're like oh this is a
different cut so this one will stay out
for 17. who knows from what I understand
the way the law works there it's meant
to give like the free TV kind of like
Network TV the opportunity to show the
film before it goes to like a paid
streaming thing uh and Disney like you
said they haven't released any of their
phase four stuff on uh Disney plus yet
because of that uh and they've also made
the decision the upcoming film strange
worlds uh uh I think it's called strange
worlds yeah they um uh they're not gonna
release that in theaters in France
they're just gonna put it out on stream
so that's kind of the question here are
they going to do that with black panther
where they don't release it so that they
can put it out on Destiny plus that's I
think that's what they're doing yeah
yeah but they're going to be everyone in
France will be spoiled yeah I guess
every single person but the message
watching the theaters I mean we haven't
seen the movie yet but God it's got a
crush well I'm sure that's what they're
thinking is like they want to be able to
get those worldwide box office numbers
yeah they love so much and France not
the biggest
significant Market well that's what I
was about to say I think if it was me
I'd be jumping that first little train
to get on the channel
or something I don't know why the UK but
maybe actually it's probably harder to
go than you okay yeah yeah go to another
European country um but that's still in
the EU it's 17 months is just I need to
know the number for that the reason for
that yeah 17 months is way too that's
that's like two years almost a sequel's
gonna come out for some movies
just like they could put it out on in
the theaters and it could go out on
other free channels they just they won't
get to put on Disney Channel I see I see
I think Disney's weighing whether or not
it's worth it could they pull in more
subscribers what's better for their
bottom line yada yada yada I bring up
the Strange World thing just because
that had a has a later release date like
in November as opposed to the release
date set for black panther were kind of
forever so it's kind of like oh they've
already pulled the trigger on that
because they're like yeah we don't care
about the box office for strange worlds
like a a brand new Disney animated film
but we know black panther is going to be
an interesting and that's like nothing
really new that they do because like you
know we know that you know they do early
releases in some countries and later
releases than others but usually that's
like a week a couple days 17 months a
lot of people in the jaggery 17 months
is really long A lot of people are
saying or someone was saying that it's
for the smaller Productions to protect
to protect the smaller Productions yeah
which I I like that I like that too um
watch Black Panther I lose my mind I'd
lose my mind and you guys in the chat
you said 91 of you said no to do you
think films should have to wait 17
months before being released on
streaming eight percent of the
executives at Disney plus well actually
maybe there should be a wreck yeah
that's how I watched like 90 of films
now it's I wait for them to show up on
streaming right yeah yeah it is but then
it's like our Marvel movies I just don't
want to be spoiled and that's my whole
thing I want to be the first to see it
too
um okay you guys okay okay okay okay
okay okay time for our discussion go
ahead and play my graphic mine not
Tommy's what graphic do you want
breakdown or thirsty
showing them we can act out thirsty
thespians so Warner Brothers as you guys
know from our thumbnail is developing a
sequel to Constantine Keanu Reeves and
the director of Francis Lawrence why is
there lying I don't know why there's the
line oh okay so Francis Lawrence will be
returning okay
everyone's very excited for this yeah
this news come out on Friday as we were
already doing the show so we didn't see
it till after the show that's what we're
talking about today because we were kind
of blown away by this like it's almost
20 years it's been it's yeah it's 2005
right it has to be almost 20 years yeah
I think 2005 is uh the first time
because I remember I saw it when I was
in like Middle School which is like 2006
2008. yeah and this was yeah I was in
middle school too yeah so Constantine is
a DC character right he's shown up in
some other things or she has shown up in
some other things right they had a
concert team that showed up on was it
Legends of tomorrow or was in the area
yeah it's an arrowverse yeah he had his
own show for a second and then it got
canceled and then he went into the
arrowverse uh with Green Arrow and then
showed up in legends of tomorrow but
yeah so he's been around the TV side of
things then he jumped into all the
animated DC movies right we had a
starring role in like the justice league
dark and all that stuff yes and then and
then now he's it looks like they're
they're bringing them back around for a
sequel with Keanu so it's okay so do you
think they're gonna treat this kind of
like how they did The Matrix are they
just gonna are they gonna talk about it
that'll be the interesting question
right A lot has happened in the Deep the
world of DC since the first one the
first one was made in a time when
nothing was really connected right right
you had X-Men movies that were connected
to each other you had Spiderman movies
that were connected to each other you
had Superman movies that were connected
you have Batman movies that were all
over them all over the place uh but
Constantine was just kind of like in its
own world and as far as I remember it I
was kind of looking up again it doesn't
make any reference to anything else in
DC so I think this was 2000 if it was
2005 yeah that's before the Dark Knight
Christian Bale Batman that's before a
lot of the stuff that we've seen and
this was almost like it reminded me as a
young lad big spawn fan uh like this was
in that kind of yeah yeah yeah dark dark
but it's like dark hero Universe right
we have things like spawn and blade yeah
Constantine like dealing with
Supernatural stuff like religious yeah
Hellboy was very popular iconography uh
but do you bring this content back in
does he is it like the Zack Snyder DC EU
like no way right I'm so torn yeah
because like do they have like they
don't have to they don't have they don't
have to because they don't have to
they're in a place now where they can
you know they're doing Joker movies
they're doing Matt Reeves Batman movies
what I like to see Constantine show up
in the Matt Reeves first
absolutely it'd be super scary
because like the whole time I'm watching
uh the Batman Matt Reeves the Batman uh
all I could think was if Superman flew
down from the sky right now it would
feel goofy as heck oh yeah right it
would just feel weird or like if Wonder
Woman showed up it would feel weird it
does this that world felt like kind of
devoid of a lot of the supernatural
stuff super grounded and yeah even like
what they did in the dark knight or in
Batman Begins with like Ra's al Ghul
would feel weird yeah I think in like
that reads the Batman so do but do you
think a constant tea could fit in there
bring in like demons I think I think how
to do it is if they they could if they
if they did it in a way where it was
like is this is this guy Supernatural is
he not does he have powers or is he just
some magician because in the comics he's
he's like a magician also as and as well
as like their you know uh for lack of a
better term their sorcerer Supreme right
right and then I think that in a little
bit of magic yeah and I think in the in
this in the last 20 years in the comics
he's become this huge character that
yeah it takes on dark side and stuff
like that so I'm torn because it's like
in the movie it's in the movies like do
do we have him step into that larger
role where he's one of the most powerful
magic wielders in all of DC and and have
it tie into a bunch of other stuff or do
we still keep it kind of small and
grounded and uh yeah I'm torn I think I
would want a more focused smaller story
um hopefully and and keep it keep it
like a true second installment as
opposed to like the The Matrix for felt
like kind of ballooned a little bit off
it definitely ballooned but I I guess
what I meant more of it was going to be
like the Matrix is it gonna just feel
like yeah it's a sequel he just got
really old oh yes yes and saying Keanu
Reeves looks bad I'm just saying is
Constantine gonna have long hair and
yeah I remember people being so mad that
he wasn't blonde because in the comics
or British now he's gonna look like
actual John Wick you know I think most
people are like Constantine love the
movie and so they're like okay I've
adjusted to this as much I mean as a
young lad I thought that's so cool oh
yeah smoking which is bad don't yeah
he's like smoking but he quits by the
way tattoo uh-huh he's got his like
cross gun oh yeah he's got a little
dragon yeah they can shoot out yeah yeah
great so okay sorry to change from this
but we do know that Constantine this
movie uh has bumped like other projects
out of the way yeah it did so we're also
agreeing that we're okay with that if we
want this concept I think so right so
what were the other ones they were gonna
do a spin-off they were gonna do another
Constantine show yeah animated no no I
think live action maybe a reboot yeah I
believe JJ Abrams that's why robot was
involved with that yes
um and I don't think it was I don't
think they were planning to have Keanu
Reeves in that at all right I think it
was just gonna be another Constantine
show I don't think it was going to be
Matt Ryan either right right which is
like a whole new thing and then there
was also this show called Madame X uh
who is Madame Xanadu Xander too
that they were going to do she which the
Variety article about that show it said
it was set in the Justice League Dark
Universe right it was a justice league
dark story so that was gonna happen it
had like a Creator attached but that has
also been like kind of shelved yeah
which kind of makes sense they're you
know WB Discovery is kind of like and if
Keanu says he's down they're like let's
just go that seems like a short fighter
like if we can get Keanu we will do this
yes you know and so this story is
interesting in a world where they're
shuffling projects in cancer but they're
canceled all of these shows so they
could bring this one to the Forefront
well they have they've also said right
that they want to promote movies again
they're they're kind of shying away from
Back to the theater we're gonna do more
theaters we're gonna get people back in
the theaters so I this is a good way if
you really believe in that canceling two
shows to get one movie I mean that's one
way to do it
and Constantine had actually had such a
crazy cast like uh until the Swinton
uh you know Rachel Vice the diamond
honzo who's like the DC you know he's
like the Nick Fury and something he's in
every DC property uh like you know they
they could bring back half those people
and it would be an amazing Sequel and
then even throw in a couple new or like
new but a couple other DC faves like
Zatanna who's been tied to Constantine a
lot
um dead man or other people like it
doesn't have to be justice league dark
but it can be something like that where
you get this mystical side of the DC
which other than Shazam we haven't
really seen sorry Justin Gillespie I
know I pronounce your name wrong just
donated a lot of money
Constantine speech and we will denounce
the Ryan Constantine no I'm joking but I
also do wanna are pulling let me just
answer some of these super chats and we
will go back yeah yeah um we got the
more Constantine speech by my boy Justin
uh Legends killed Legends killed Matt
Ryan so I don't see him anymore
um well we're also gonna kill Matt Ryan
he's out uh give my cheeky British
snarky Constantine I love Keanu so but
it just doesn't hit right all right
I think that was one based on things
yeah uh J rhymney Leah said I think made
it today live with my rock stars is a
trash bags dream come true
hey if you're alive hit that like button
and if you're not live hit that like
button I need motivation I have three
more hours of work baby
uh we're on the break room right now
which is work damn this work then we got
more work after that
roasting me get some glasses Jessica
oh damn
right you are completely right I left
them at home she's doing blue steel okay
this is any glasses the MJ uh 2997 wants
some Andor motivation listen it's and or
week we're definitely gonna talk and or
today we don't have time we'll have
plenty of time to talk about Android
today uh uh we're gonna talk about into
our week we have to decide when we're
gonna talk about Andrew guys we have to
watch three episodes oh yeah I think I
think Thursday uh we're gonna be talking
about She-Hulk obviously all right
on Thursdays the yeah
so midnight to 20th season three so
we'll kind of space out how we talk
about that show here because I need time
to digest that's going to be good
oh my God Justin you almost there's
three people down there you're gonna
kill them
our Brandon so that's which Brandon is
that was it this one or is it is it our
Brandon or is it this one our Brandon I
only have one brand in my life
I don't know how to do because okay wait
okay so you gotta like yellow you gotta
say like you gotta like throw your hands
like somebody I just took your parking
spot like just just like what you guys
Brandon is really aggressive
hey you trash bags you folks out there
um it's he kind of has a Brooklyn kind
of voice but it's not Brooklyn at all
he's just upset
yeah you got a little bit Gruff or
something
um you guys my name is Brandon Barry oh
oh boy oh geez motivate them they got
three more you guys are doing so great
for three hours of work it's so hard I
love Jubilee and I'm never gonna get
enough of it
Jubilee Jubilee who's the other guy that
you like oh my God the old time he was
right in the Civil War no it's the it's
the old night host that old guy that you
love so much that you keep talking about
David Letterman dick
Dick Cavett you have three hours of work
you'll make it you'll get through it
you'll be able to gum through on the
other side and when you do it'll be
great and amazing and all that hard work
will pay off because in two weeks or
maybe even this week you'll get paid and
you know what you'll do and you'll get
paid to get drinks you get food you have
a smart time Dick Cavett dick cabbage
I make one reference I make one
reference one reference who's Brandon
all right all right one two one I guess
two Tom I can't whoa oh Jess you're back
wait what that was crazy
you didn't have to make fun
that was that was awesome
whoa both of you guys get to see it
though does she still doing her branding
guys it's a Brandon within a Brandon
it's like Inception I'll Crump with you
honey
oh there you guys like my Marge Simpson
my Marge Simpson ones she could have put
her on the board I should have put an
actual cartoon character it's not this
cartoon character wow Jess thank you
that was very that was great that was
great I'm sorry I don't know about you I
feel motivated Kevin is still alive dick
Heaven is not still he's still alive no
he is he lives he's living breathing
he's a happy man okay sorry well uh
apologies today Kevin nice dragon
sitting in a Super Chat saying I don't
mind Vince Vaughn's part of the team but
I want to hear more from just the diva
people have said I sound like Vince
Vaughn I was wondering what they were
talking about it's like it's my Cadence
I don't know if it's like it's not
because there's no New York but it feels
like I was gonna say is Vince Vaughn
from Florida
yeah I am from Florida and Florida is
like a weird place that doesn't really
have an accent yeah yeah it's where all
the the [ __ ] from the country dribbles
down in there it's like the funnel
catches in the colostomy bag of Florida
by the way as a resume born and raised
I'm allowed to say that hey uh you know
one thing about Florida is it is a
coastal city it's got tons of Coastline
uh and it's very very much in the line
of danger and threat from climate change
folks uh the oceans are rising and
Florida could be wiped out in a second
we don't want to see that it's true it's
true uh and you know we all want to make
those small decisions every day to help
the planet that can have a big impact
over time but if you keep your money in
most standard bank accounts they're
lending your deposits out to fund oil
and coal and all those nasty things that
are destroying the planet switch to the
planet's side and get aspiration we want
to thank our our friends and aspiration
for sponsoring the break room today
aspiration is a climate-friendly
alternative to Big Banks you can get an
account and debit card that's built to
help your wallet and the planet moving
one thousand dollars to an aspiration
Plus account has the same impact as
driving 6 000 miles less you're
offsetting the equipment football right
there plus you can earn up to 71 times
as much interest than at your old Bank
aspiration is fossil fuel free and lets
you plant a tree by rounding up every
swipe of your debit card that's right if
you do that little Roundup they'll plant
a tree uh for every time you swipe your
car it's great aspiration's been hard at
work helping people align their money
with their values funding the planet of
over 100 million trees that's right 100
million trees and they're on their way
to funding the uh the planting of 1
billion trees by 2030 1 billion with the
B it's no wonder why Forbes nerd wallet
and the penny boarder recommend
aspiration uh for their ego conscious
nature we want we we have to do our part
to help the planet and you can make that
easier with a debit card from aspiration
best of all there's no credit check no
overdraft fees and with aspiration you
just pay what you think is fair even if
that's zero because money shouldn't
stand in the way of doing the right
thing make your dollars make a
difference open an aspiration account at
aspiration.com break room debit and move
your money out of fossil fuels again
help save the planet with your
aspiration debit card open your account
at aspiration.com break room debit today
aspiration.com
terms and conditions do apply hey hey I
got a question for you too yeah have you
ever gotten like a free shirt somewhere
I like a con oh yeah I love a free shirt
uh my wife hates that about me if
there's a free shirt I'm taking it it's
coming back same I'm moving on an
expensive shirt to keep my free shirt
you know what I mean that's the psycho
rifle but a lot of times you get that
for sure and it's crappy right it's
crummy it's thin it's terrible the logo
is poorly printed on there it's awful
and you're like how is this how why are
they promoting their business with this
right well you should have the best
material and the best promo material
available if you're going to promote
your business thousands of businesses
have relied on lands and business to
outfit their employees and promote their
brand they offer timeless style that
fits everybody type with the widest
range of sizes you'll find in branded
apparel you can have your logo in Vivid
colors on t-shirts outerwear hats mugs
water bottles and more hundreds of
products perfect for any trade show
event or holiday gift or if you're just
trying to come up with a uniform for
your staff you want the model look nice
right state-of-the-art state of the art
design and stitching technology turns
your logo into an instantly recognizable
work of art that's right a beautiful
workout of art cut it out hang it up in
a museum they have customer service that
goes above and beyond you get email chat
and phone support from a customer
service team eager to help every
business is treated like a VIP whether
you have five employees or 500 employees
see why thousands of companies count on
lands and business go to
business.landsand.com podcast and use
promo code podcast for 25 off that's
business.lands and.com slash podcast
promo code podcast for 25 off
damn yeah damn yeah also you guys I keep
grabbing this microphone like if you
keep taking the microphone give it a mic
wait I don't want to get demons
sorry sorry are you guys in the chat we
see you guys in the chat going off
sounding off about your location and I
wouldn't be the mom of the break room if
I said please don't disclose yourself
closing their location you guys are all
sounded off about where you are and just
if you guys are just know be safe about
it yeah planet Earth in the house you
can do that too some would say Orlando I
was born in Orlando
I was born in Orlando in 2002. oh my God
same year as me great
it took me a minute what's funny about
that damn second I was born in 2002. you
guys it's time for mandatory fun yeah
play it one more time no no no no
[Music]
time
six espresso shots has hitting me in my
stomach so you're gonna have six playing
four six times
oh
I love that girl you asked for that
graphic I I that's not what I envisioned
you guys and my notes were not taken
John said no I'm just gonna go off with
it yeah um you guys Titania if you have
you heard of her Titania AKA Jamil Jamil
wow New York Fashion Week by appearing
and character as titanium from She-Hulk
I don't know if we have any little asset
of it do we I don't
in Titania outfit has been doing so much
PR yeah she went around and like here in
La she like spray painted Street the
same She-Hulk posters she's been going
post no bills she posted bills oh no
well she has a reason because she's like
an influencer but I was like I don't
know how many other like MCU shows or
movies gets that into PR that they're
like oh we're gonna send this person
that's a famous actress to go out and
yeah oh do you want to go in the wild
huh spin the wheel you want to do this
now in the middle of mandatory fun yeah
okay make it more fun also someone said
he has risen
my Marvel special presentation now if I
get me do I have to do me oh no
Jessica how does he sound like just uh
be like yeah that's a tell me yeah since
2004. I just think of her in candy which
I don't know if you've seen it was it
candy or was it honey wasn't it was
honey wait she's in Honey she's the
dinner oh but there's a new show oh I'm
thinking of Jessica Beale sorry I was
thinking okay sorry guys I would have
put my nerd card away I gotta go yes
[Laughter]
this is Jessica Alba giving you a
motivational speech
hey it's me Jessica Alba I know you
haven't seen you for a long time but
that's because I've been running my own
clean yeah Green okay cleaning products
line called honest I think no it's um I
can't remember I don't remember what
it's called but it makes me a lot of
money yeah and listen I know a lot of
you nerds out there made fun of me for
Fantastic Four but you would have taken
that contract too and I did the best I
could okay but this is a motivational
Monday and so I'm gonna be motivational
for you
you can do it I was in Honey okay a
movie about dancing and I barely dance
but I did it because I believed in
myself and you can believe in yourself
too and if you've got to spare a couple
million dollars you can start your own
Clean cleaning products company with
green chemicals that will not hurt your
babies and will not hurt your pets take
it from me Jessica Alba whatever you
want
they gave me a driver's license I don't
know how to drive a car
one time when I was on an airplane they
were like Jessica do you want do you fly
and I said absolutely not but I did it
anyways because I believed in myself
go out there get a piece of paper write
down five things you want to do today
eat that paper what and by the time it
passes through your system you will have
done those things take it from me
Jessica Alba oh my God I believe in you
Namaste wow the thing is when I did go
into Paltrow it was kind of like the
problematic and Jessica Alba not I think
she's less problematic I think she has
less also one person I think it was
quitting in the chat brought up the best
Jessica Alba film which is Idol idol
hands I remember that he knows her first
major role a lot of cameos in that is
Seth Green everyone comes up in that
movie it's a good one okay okay
so now we're back into mandatory fun
okay so Titania's been appearing
everywhere she went to New York she's
dressed up that guy's wondering what
characters from the MCU should start
showing up at real life events you know
uh anything anything the Dodgers game
that's my first one
um the Mardi Gras I mean well really
Captain America should show up at a
Dodgers game
[Music]
why she wake up being frozen on the
radio it's like and here comes the
Dodgers in Los Angeles gonna be like no
who wants to go first what character
anyways what character do we want to see
do you go somewhere else hmm they should
have had they should have like Stephen
Grant give tours at a at a museum right
and then freak out oh my God but what
museum
you talking about like the Smithsonian
dude no at the London Museum where are
you supposed to work on the show it
could be enemies it could go to like a
kid Zone Discovery Space in front of all
little kids and be like I'll just
blocked out what happened look at all
the kids are in the corner like they're
like three of us his hands are bloody
he's like oh no no okay
it wasn't me why am I holding this
bloody billy clubs
[Laughter]
I do want to see like
um like Robert Downey it would probably
be Iron Man but I'd like to see like the
entire Avengers be like we need to go on
like a team building we need to go on a
team building
and yeah a rope of course but they do go
to Mardi Gras they go to Mardi Gras
they're just all wasted yeah
the store has that special specialized
Guardian ale or whatever yeah he's got a
special juice I can't get wasted that's
a problem because I think it would be
Iron Man it would be Tony Stark for
preparing the event we know Tony Stark
can get wasted oh he's seen it we've
seen it yeah hey you guys want to see me
pee in the suit
you can drink it you could drink it
who else would be who else is out there
that we could see in different events
Wong would probably be at the premiere
of this is us because he loves this is
us how does Wong just not actually
appear in premieres because she should
just show up to all of them just come
right out uh on the chat saying Madison
yeah you should have just Madison do
like a bar tour like how they'll have
members they used to have members of
like the real world or like World rules
go to like college bars yeah
could you imagine if they did next like
the old MTV show but with Marvel
Cinematic Universe and Madison's hosting
it yeah she's like next she's like I'm
sorry he just has too much going on I
can't stop wearing a shirt oh
I was saying uh what if uh you know if
Obi-Wan from the show went to like um uh
went to like birding man you wouldn't
even notice you he didn't look any
different at all or if you went to
Coachella he just showed up yeah
and then at night he could be him
that's right yeah he'd be like sell me
dubsticks somebody sell me death sticks
I need some right yeah
we do well burning man because Qui-Gon
he [ __ ] man oh yeah yeah
gets down oh yeah he's trying to tell
Obi-Wan before all that stuff goes off
like they're when they're on their way
to like talk to like uh the nemodians or
whatever they're on the ship and he's
like I'm gonna tell you all about how to
be a Jedi don't look at that book stuff
hold on we're gonna deal with this real
fast and I'm gonna tell you all about it
and then everything gets derived and
gets cut and he dies in it yeah he was
actually he's actually taking Obi-Wan to
his first strip club but then it didn't
work out because the whole movie
happened yeah yeah
kid's mom hook up oh it's not in the
movie bro either way it's in Brandon's
head
who do you think would like my whole
part is like who would be like the host
or not the host like the camp counselor
who would be like at a summer camp for
kids would be the number one camp
counselor
I mean Hawkeye has a lot of experience
with kids that's true and if they get
too loud he can just turn off his
hearing uh hearing piece I think Thor
has shown he could handle it maybe he he
dealt with a bunch of kids who've been
kidnapped you know who'd be good one
Falcons because Sam Wilson is an actual
counselor he had people through some
sorry Captain America yeah Captain
Falcon he could do it I agree with both
of you but I lean more for Hawkeye only
because archery oh yeah
he's gonna let them all take a turn on
the backpack Smokey's cooking kid oh
he's gonna he's gonna play catch with
them with the shield yeah Loki no no I'm
sorry Psychopaths and I think that's why
uh Loki's gonna give them all little
knives do you want to give us some of
your life okay I'll give you some
scenarios and feel free to pray along in
the chat if you like uh these are
scenarios you have to bring either a
villain or a hero with you to these
scenarios and you go outside the MCU for
this okay okay you're having dinner with
your family and not just your immediate
family like cousins and stuff you got to
bring someone who you bring in
like bring home the mom type not not as
a date you have to bring them to your
family dinner and be responsible for
them the whole time whatever they say
it's on you Sam Wilson okay that's
Captain America that's safe uh I'm gonna
bring uh sir Kristen Cole in case
something goes down so he's one of my
family members no he
yeah this isn't live so rewind yeah he
said you can do anything so I said to
Crystal because sometimes it gets a
little ham with my family and I need to
make sure someone got my back you need
to make sure he busts your dad exactly
exactly could be like who'd you vote for
all right get out of here get in here he
can give that treatment to a couple of
my customers
gotta go to a you got a meeting with
your boss to get a promotion who you
bringing with you hello I'm bringing um
the best hype Girl in Town Nikki from
sheahawk she was gonna help me feel so
good she's gonna hype me up the make me
feel so good about myself and I'm gonna
Crush that yeah uh I'm gonna bring Thor
because I think it's all about uh looks
I think it's all about eye candy and if
you bring in Thor you'll get in and
games
dad bringing Nick Fury dude he'll do all
my negotiating forms uh you gotta go to
church who are you bringing with you
okay Marty said Thor and I already said
um I'm going to church
uh I'm gonna bring the Scarlet Witch
just
to prove everyone in church
just to prove them wrong Feast your eyes
on this Believers where is your God now
I turn you into spaghetti I'm gonna
bring Constantine to fight Scarlet Witch
get right into church and then if
there's any other demons he can excise
all of them so we'll be safe yeah yeah
the priest will be like Constantine yeah
exactly hey I know that guy I don't know
Scarlet Witch but I know that guy that's
pretty funny I was gonna say you bring
Bucky Barnes because he can be
brainwashed oh got him
yeah all right all right all right you
gotta go break up with your partner it's
gonna go bad who are you gonna bring
okay okay okay what are you gonna bring
with you I think I'm gonna bring
Valkyrie because I think Valkyrie would
be like stop crying at
that Valkyrie would hide me up in a bad
way but
I'm gonna I'm gonna bring cork you know
he's got a gentle approach it'll be like
sometimes things you still woke up you
know you just gotta move on and it's
okay okay and it'll just go on for until
so long until they just fall asleep and
they'll just be so gentle about it we
only need a couple more to get to 300
but I do want to see you spin that wheel
and I've already had to do one bad one
and he did one good one no yo Jessica
Alba you're uh your Brandon was amazing
Brandon you're our Brandon yeah that was
so good Ted Chapman said you got to
bring Daredevil to church that's a good
one oh that's a good one
Doctor Strange so he won't run out of
communion wine I mean bring him back to
strange might also uh yeah
bring oh bring your vision to a breakup
would be a good idea that would be a
good one bringing white Vision to church
white Vision
like I believe everything you're saying
yeah it must be true the regular Vision
can come in with that with that hot [ __ ]
like what is what is a breakup but not
love persevering okay you have to have
someone crash on your couch for six
weeks they have to stay with you for six
weeks at your house and it's not all the
fun I mean I'm talking about when you
just want to be alone and they're there
you just want to watch TV and they're
talking to you yeah easy okay nebula
nebula not gonna eat all my food and
will hate me more than I hate her oh
that's true she will leave me alone
it's a good one I mean I think Steve
Rogers has got to be the best house
guests out there he's not gonna cost
anyone he's gonna do all the dishes he
puts away the sheets and he's like hey I
folded your laundry today he doesn't
understand a lot of things so he'd be
like oh I didn't even know you could
clean with this and I'd be like were you
just using water yeah yeah I feel like
that steel pan rubbing clothes in your
living room where did you even get that
he would be yelling so goddamn breaking
like the router he's like how do I get
on the line turn it down
he screams
oh okay yeah
you're right I have he's like that feels
like it feels like I'm sleeping on a
marshmallow I'm gonna be over the
sinking like Taco Bell and he's like
doing
117 exactly 180 I'm like get this you're
right he's like you're on roids bro okay
that ain't natural he wouldn't buy
equipment either he just used the house
so he'd be like on a frame like cool
and he's always behind you just like on
your left you're like God okay geez we
need a bigger place it just went away
but someone in the chat uh said Vision
white Vision the holy friendly ghosts
go spin this wheel really quick
Christina
G is jessalyn for the green eyeshadow
also you're all amazing thank you uh
Chris Jim Chris Christian
those are unpronounceable oh that's the
name uh says I'm home trash bags buy
yourself something pretty okay
says cold cuts you got back Batman I got
Jessica Alba again and I was like I
don't know why I can talk so I was like
I gotta spin again Stacy C said Sorry by
Jessica Alba motivational speech eating
my life goals as we speak please donate
your life goals unless
I think once you do that's actually
absorbing it and it actually comes out
with advice not my advice it's also
Jessica Clements you take it from her uh
we will go out on a motivational Batman
speech here uh reminder tomorrow's our
100th episode please tune in
me Brandon Tommy a special guest uh uh
make sure you tune in for that uh we're
so excited to celebrate 100 episodes and
we'll be dressed to the tens we are the
20s you're dressing up yeah I'm dressing
like it's a funeral but some people are
dressing up like it's Christmas I guess
I'll dress up maybe Dave Dave Owens
having Wolverine crash on his couch the
cigarette the song I smoke alone
PTSD we're talking about nightmares
or be like hey Logan you're waiting it's
gonna stab you with me I'm gonna stab
you with the chest oh my God I've seen
your Uber Eats is here
[Laughter]
imagine you're like sleeping every night
he's just standing over your bed like in
Logan you're like wait are you about to
stab me in the chest like dude you can't
keep doing this I'm gonna put a lock on
my door right exactly exactly oh and new
Rockstar is probably out it's got to be
seamless staying on the couch of course
you can crash at my place anytime come
on Michelle you can sing You Can Dance
give him a little Batman motivation to
get into Mondays all right since
everyone knows uh Christian Bale I'm
gonna do some uh some battenson Batman
we gotta get in the mood first
hey everybody
well I hope you hope you're doing good
today
you know you're doing a lot better than
me because I live in Gotham where
tonight all the time oh yeah I don't
have anything to do but punch people in
the face and sometimes I run out of eye
shadow and you can see the skin around
my eyes and it's just so embarrassing
and you don't got that problem because
you're not me so you should be living it
up having a good day doing everything
you can you should be going to Starbucks
getting six shots of espresso in there
just like me I got a little belt with
this green little syringe where I can
put in like 24 shots of espresso that's
too much for you just just live life
normally you know and be thankful you
don't have to be like me and beat up
criminals with bare fists oh man I just
really want to listen to some Nirvana
right now oh God I think Jessica finds a
pornography
oh geez oh baby oh my God
have a good day
sexual motivation over there uh thank
you for tuning in be sure to tune in
tomorrow
hit that like button uh uh join join the
Discord do everything you gotta do uh uh
we love you we thank you for tuning in
have a great rest of your Monday we'll
see you tomorrow live on the break room
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you